[Música]
ah
en una decisión histórica a suecia y
finlandia abandonaron su neutralidad
militar y anunciaron su incorporación a
la otan la organización del atlántico
norte la alianza militar que lidera eeuu
y a la cual hacen parte de ella varios
países europeos la alianza que surgió
precisamente después de la segunda
guerra mundial y que se extendió tras la
caída de la unión soviética la razón la
amenaza que representa a tener un vecino
como rusia finlandia en particular tiene
una historia que la une a ese país ya en
el pasado finlandia fue parte del
imperio ruso en medio de la revolución
se independizó y solamente tres meses
después del inicio de la segunda guerra
mundial fue invadida por el ejército
rojo en la guerra de invierno
el temor finlandés a una incursión
similar la ha llevado a tener un
ejército pequeño pero muy bien entrenado
y técnicamente muy avanzado pero también
más de 1300 kilómetros de frontera con
rusia son más que suficiente para tomar
medidas preventivas ante las acciones y
también los argumentos y amenazas
recientes por parte del kremlin y eso
implica abandono 80 años de neutralidad
así lo anunció el presidente finlandés
soul y listo
hoy el presidente de la república y el
comité de política exterior del gobierno
acordaron conjuntamente que finlandia
solicitará el ingreso en la otan pero es
contra culto a anna aunque notorias en
el tal
previa consulta el parlamento han pasado
muchas cosas desde la última vez que nos
reunimos aquí el 24 de febrero este es
un día histórico un nuevo camino se abre
y que colom está sin tener pasto
suecia no tiene frontera con rusia pero
frente a sus costas está el enclave ruso
de kaliningrado en donde permanecen o
permanentemente hay presencia militar
rusa la posibilidad de un movimiento
hacia finlandia hace temer a estocolmo
que rusia después de finlandia quiera
avanzar hacia suecia también la extensa
industria militar sueca ha estado
involucrada en el conflicto ucraniano a
través de la unión europea un argumento
que moscú puede usar en su contra al
menos ese es parte del análisis que han
hecho varios medios de comunicación en
suecia a lo largo de la semana y del fin
de semana sobre su proceso de
incorporación a la bota se refirió la
primera ministra de suecia magdalena'
anderson
extensa material tras el debate en el
parlamento de mossos celebrado una
reunión extra del gobierno en la que
hemos tomado dos decisiones en primer
lugar el gobierno ha decidido informar a
la otan que suecia desea convertirse en
miembro de la alianza y muy pronto el
embajador sueco de la otan informará de
ello a la alianza
después de eso comenzarán las
negociaciones para la adhesión suecia y
la otan tienen una larga historia
conjunta de cope y simulacros y
esfuerzos internacionales así que eso es
algo que debería facilitar esas
negociaciones
rusia respondió en cierta forma mejor de
lo que la comunidad internacional
pensaba tras semanas de amenazas a
suecia finlandia el presidente ruso
vladimir putin dijo que no importa si
estos países se incorporan a la otan lo
que temen es el despliegue de armamento
en esos dos países pero entonces porque
si puede tener una relación sin amenazas
con noruega que es un país con el que
tiene fronteras y que además es
integrante de la otan estas fueron las
palabras del presidente ruso vladimir
putin escuchamos
en cuanto a la expansión de la otan e
incluso a través con la inclusión de los
nuevos miembros de la alianza en libia y
suecia quiero informarles que ni los
colegas que rusia no tiene ningún
problema con esos estados entonces en
este sentido la expansión por la adición
de nuestros países no representa una
amenaza directa para nosotros pero la
expansión de la infraestructura militar
en este territorio ciertamente
provocaría nuestra respuesta cuál sería
veremos que amenazas se crean para
nosotros dijo gross katrina en bolsas de
abad
se preguntarán ustedes por las
reacciones a nivel internacional pues ha
habido de todo tipo no se han hecho
esperar por supuesto con este tamaño de
noticia que ha dado suecia y finlandia
pero el presidente turco recep tayib
erdogán rechazó por completo las
aspiraciones de estos dos países
nórdicos de ingresar a la otan una
alianza de la que turquía hace
precisamente parte también el argumento
pues para ankara suecia es un refugio de
terroristas y por lo tanto no contará
con su apoyo para su ingreso
las delegaciones sueca y finlandesa
vendrán a turquía el lunes que sólo va a
personar
personas vienen a convencernos disculpen
pero no deberían gastar energía ya
obtener en primer lugar no aceptaríamos
que quienes imponen sanciones a turquía
se unan a la otan de dicho plan
por qué entonces la otan dejaría de ser
una organización de seguridad y se
convertiría en un lugar donde se
concentran los representantes de las
organizaciones terroristas terroristas
en aguas estaba
la incorporación de suecia y finlandia
la otan representa entonces una nueva
chispa de inestabilidad en europa como
podrá actuar la impredecible rusia aquí
juega turquía en todo este conflicto qué
significa para la otan que estos dos
países que militarmente están muy
tecnificado sí muy modernos y además
organizados se incorporen se abre
entonces un nuevo debate sobre ese
concepto de neutralidad que había en
varios países de europa existe todavía
la neutralidad hoy en el debate de
france24 suecia y finlandia a la otan
que ahora rusia para analizar este tema
saludamos a zaira vadillo ella es
analista internacional historiadora de
rusia y la unión soviética la señora
vadillo estudia los procesos políticos
en el espacio soviético con foco en asia
central y en el cáucaso ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de londres en el
reino unido también está con nosotros
antonio barrios oviedo él es analista
especialista en conflictos
internacionales en origen y ampliación
de la otan es también docente invitado
en la universidad del medio oriente él
se encuentra en la ciudad de san josé en
costa rica ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en el debate
con todos sus comentarios y preguntas
las pueden hacer a través de nuestras
redes sociales ya usted las conocen en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24
s arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal y nuestra etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 para que conversé con
nosotros y deje todos sus comentarios y
preguntas comienzo entonces con esa ira
en la ciudad de londres bienvenida al
programa salida gracias por estar con
nosotros en el debate de france 24 y
comienzo con esa pregunta que dejaba
sobre la mesa esta decisión de suecia y
finlandia de unirse a la otan es otra
chispa de inestabilidad en europa cuál
es su análisis
bueno esta decisión
honestamente cambia todo el juego la de
otra lidad que ha mantenido finlandia
por tantas décadas y luego la forma tan
cautelosa en que suez se ha manejado sus
relaciones con rusia pueden de repente
viene a un fin si deciden unirse a
dotado a pesar de que putin ha dicho que
no considera esto tal amenaza hasta que
haya una infra su infraestructura
militar en sus fronteras yo creo que
esto sí va a traer problemas a largo
plazo y va a crear mucha inestabilidad
también dentro de la otan porque
claramente erdogán se ha expresado en
contra de que suecia y finlandia sean
parte de la organización que yo creo que
esto hay un margen de negociación que le
está buscando pero yo creo que en estos
días hemos visto unos movimientos y unas
decisiones de distintos países que
realmente van a cambiar la geopolítica
de toda europa y son altamente
preocupantes sabemos que rusia ya tiene
una historia de verdad en relación a
finlandia en el pasado
ocupando una región que en aquel
entonces para hacer una guerra mundial
pertenecía finlandia así que hay una
ansiedad de parte del liderato finlandés
y lo mismo sucede en suecia que no es un
país que tiene una defensa tan sólida
como tal vez finlandia ha venido
desarrollando en los últimos diez años
así que sí me parece que esta decisión
también erdogán y putin algo que ha sido
cauteloso me parece que es de preocupar
antonio en la ciudad de san josé en
costa rica también le doy la bienvenida
del programa y punto de partida a la
misma pregunta es esto otra chispa de
inestabilidad otro punto de un comienzo
de otro episodio de inestabilidad en
europa que ahora involucra no países del
este sino países nórdicos sí sin duda yo
creo que va a ser una situación de
inestabilidad política más que militar a
mediano o largo plazo yo creo que
conforme se vayan
redefiniendo los patrones geopolíticos
que vinieron a cambiar radicalmente la
guerra nuclear ni una guerra que a pesar
de que se presagiaba se decía que no iba
a ocurrir incluso el mismo putin así lo
manifestó y lanza después una invasión
militar en ucrania yo creo que la guerra
nuclear ni estaría pasando aún a un
segundo término aunque no menos
importante porque yo creo que ahora la
fijación de putin va a ser en el tema de
finlandia putin ya lo dijo muy
claramente no tiene ningún problema en
que estos países entren pero yo creo que
lo dijo más en función de que no están
condenen condición militar por lo menos
no puede jugarse en chance político
a cabo otra incursión militar
similar a la de ucrania tratando de
meter contra finlandia y yo creo que lo
que estaría buscando eventualmente es
tratar de suavizar un poco la situación
que ha venido ocurriendo y sí por lo
menos dejar sobre la mesa el hecho de
que no tiene parte en que finlandia sea
parte de la otan pero mucho ojo respecto
al tipo de equipo militar que vayan a
poner cerca la frontera como usted bien
lo dijo anteriormente son 1300
kilómetros de frontera es decir no es
una frontera despreciable del punto de
vista geopolítico y eso yo creo que sí
digamos va a haber va a ser un punto de
tensión que no de guerra si un punto de
atención sobre los movimientos militares
tanto de un lado como de otro que
pudieran generar la incorporación de
finlandia y a la estructura de la otan
1300 kilómetros de frontera común tres
provincias que eran de finlandia pasaron
a ser parte de la unión soviética
después de la guerra de invierno y
también hay que recordar a menos de 250
kilómetros de esa frontera está san
petersburgo que es la segunda ciudad más
grande de rusia y tiene un punto
estratégico a nivel militar por ser la
puerta del báltico para rusia
importante para rusia tomar decisiones
en cuanto a los movimientos que hagan
finlandia y suecia cómo puede salir a
reaccionar rusia
siendo un país tan impredecible como
hemos visto a lo largo de estas semanas
y estos meses en el conflicto de ucrania
que dice no vamos a invadir invade todas
las semanas había una amenaza distinta
hacia finlandia hacia suecia hacia los
países bálticos hacia ucrania pero ahora
la respuesta de putin tal vez baja un
poco más las aguas pero rusia no se va a
quedar quieta cómo puede responder
bueno siempre está la amenaza del gas ya
hubo
en relación a la electricidad también
rusia acaba de cortar el acceso a
electricidad que apenas un 10% para
finlandia y bueno está el asunto del gas
que siempre como tal la forma en que
amenaza putin a muchos de sus países
alrededor pero yo diría que tiene que
ser más que cauteloso porque finlandia y
los rusos al otro lado de la frontera
mantienen relaciones comerciales
bastante estrechas los pueblos en la
frontera dependen cada uno del otro es
muy común que los rusos tengan
vamos a decir casas de verano en
finlandia que vayan a los centros
comerciales a comprar cosas así que hay
un constante tal vez ahora no tanto como
antes pero en constante flujo migratorio
entre ambos fronteras no así que putin
debe ser muy cauteloso en lo que va a
hacer porque en relación al menos con
finlandia todavía la población rusa en
esta región depende tiene dos ciertos
lazos comercial y se benefician
mutuamente porque también benefician a
los pueblos y las ciudades que están al
otro lado de la frontera de rusia así
que hay que ver ya sabemos que en
relación a electricidad no va a seguir
previendo de electricidad a finlandia
pero era apenas un 10% así que en ese
sentido como bien ustedes han mencionado
putin no está ahora en la capacidad de
estar manejando militarmente a otro de
sus vecinos y a pesar de que finlandia
es un país que relativamente digamos no
tiene una población tan grande de 45
millones de población en relación a
rusia que son 200 millones tal vez ahí
todo el mundo tiene la obligación de
servir militarmente no es uno de los
pocos países junto a israel donde a una
obligación para todos los jóvenes de ser
todo a servir así que tiene un ejército
militar muy preparado muy grande y una
defensa bastante sólida así que en ese
sentido habría que esperar cuáles son
las decisiones que vladimir putin va a
tomar en relación a finlandia lo digo
porque ya finlandia rusia tiene una
historia ahí pero de la misma forma que
tiene una historia han desarrollado
también unos lazos y cortarlo va a
afectar a ambas partes si finlandia
siempre ha funcionado como una especie
de para el colchón entre occidente y ha
logrado
llevar una buena relación con moscú
independientes y eran la época soviética
o en la actual administración del
presidente finlandia logrado mantener
una buena relación precisamente por esa
vida binacional que tienen en la
república de karelia ya el otro lado de
la frontera en finlandia precisamente
con una relación bastante estable sólida
y sin ningún tipo de agresión es la que
tiene rusia con noruega que es un país
que es otan con quien tiene fronteras
con quien incluso comparte parte de la
administración de un archipiélago en el
norte de las islas de svalbard tiene una
relación cordial esto puede ser un buen
ejemplo para esta cordialidad entre
estocolmo helsinki moscú y bajar un poco
el ánimo entre estos tres países como lo
ve usted antonio yo creo que yo creo que
noruega puede jugar un papel muy
importante de la acción o de la frontera
que comparte con rusia prácticamente es
una frontera esté muy corta no no no no
reviste digamos una situación de amenaza
como como la ha venido percibiendo putin
desde que empezó esta situación de
conflicto y como ve en el caso de
finlandia que estamos hablando de 1300
kilómetros pero si yo creo que noruega
como país nórdico perfectamente puede
jugar un papel muy importante frente a
estos 82 que a pesar de que han
mantenido una neutralidad cuando más
bien tanto la primera ministra como el
de ambos países tanto de finlandia como
de suecia pues no hablan de que han sido
neutrales sino que han sido por ejemplo
aliados estratégicos de la otan aunque
no necesariamente miembros plenos
aceptados dentro la estructura
yo creo que noruega puede jugar un papel
muy importante incluso yo creo también
que el caso de turquía es interesante
porque turquía lo que está buscando
también es buscar sopesar qué papel
podría estar desempeñando erdogán en
esta situación con respecto a finlandia
y respecto a suecia así que yo creo que
algunos actores 9 quieren entrar en esta
escena para ver qué papel pueden jugar y
que incluso el rol de poder pueden estar
llegando a tener sobre lo que
significaría la incorporación de
finlandia y de suecia dentro de la otan
antonio tengo el tema de turquía más
adelante en la agenda para que lo
analicemos desde diferentes puntos de
vista ya vamos para allá quiero terminar
por analizar un poco este concepto de
neutralidad 80 años finlandia ha sido un
país neutral allí en el norte de suecia
ya por casi un siglo o un poco más ha
declarado su neutralidad y
rompen esta tradición histórica en estos
dos países al determinar este movimiento
pero que tanto se puede hablar de este
concepto de neutralidad en europa porque
por ejemplo también vemos el caso de
suiza que
clama a ser un país neutral pero
claramente está aplicando las sanciones
internacionales contra rusia eso la pone
claramente en un bando y ha habido
muchos debates en el parlamento suizo
también la misma situación se ve en
irlanda en otros países como austria
en qué concepto estamos hablando ahorita
de neutralidad de salida
disculpen bueno la neutralidad todo va a
depender de cómo lo miren ya en los 90
podríamos decir que finlandia ya se
empezó a asociar con la unión europea
empezaron a establecer muy buenas
relaciones formó parte del euro en el 99
por tal razón
ya habían empezado a desarrollarse unos
lazos muy estrechos en relación a suecia
suecia fue parte del otan y de de la
organización militar que se llevó a cabo
en afganistán de toda su organización y
obviamente tuvo presencia militar es así
que la neutralidad yo diría que después
del 91 ha perdido hasta cierto punto
su relevancia en relación a europa
claramente han tomado unas posiciones
muy claras
punto importante antonio su concepto de
esta neutralidad que se está viviendo
uno en europa o estamos ante el inicio
del nuevo capítulo de este concepto ya
irlanda lo dijo muy claro puede que
seamos neutrales militarmente pero no
neutrales moralmente así lo dijeron en
el gobierno irlandés referente al tema
de ucrania
sí bueno yo creo que la neutralidad de
concuerdo con un niño zaira es una
cuestión a veces de conveniencia pero
dada la situación de guerra en ucrania y
el temor de lo que putin pues puede ser
capaz de hacer quizás con otros países
pues evidentemente a veces hay que dejar
de lado los países deben de dejar de
lado eso porque aquí digamos gana el
temor ante situaciones tan impredecibles
con las que digamos putin ha venido
actuando toda la toda la gran cantidad
de amenazas con los cuales putin pues ha
venido más allá de lo militar en ucrania
ha venido hablando también sobre el
emplazamiento de armamento estratégico
con algunas fronteras lo cual pues pone
un poco digamos en entredicho la
estabilidad de europa y respecto al tema
nuclear que es algo pues que
evidentemente genera siempre mucho temor
y bueno yo creo que la sexualidad acá
también usted lo dijo muy bien el tema
cuando hay que actuar moralmente yo creo
que hay que dejar muchas otras cosas de
lado y evidentemente si bien algunos
países no son parte de la otan si son
parte de la umh europea y han tenido que
sumarse digamos a esta situación de
sanciones en contra encontrar luz y en
donde también por sus habitantes han
tenido que aplicar su batería de contra
sanciones para ver cómo logra y saliendo
adelante pero yo creo que estamos en un
nuevo capítulo en donde esta situación
de inestabilidad o esta relación de
rusia con europa va a durar muchísimos
años en poder éste resolverse
positivamente porque va a quedar en el
aire y en el ambiente europeo una
situación de desconfianza por muchos
años
antonio rusia dentro de las reacciones
que hubo después de estos anuncios en el
gobierno en el kremlin dijo que si estos
dos países incorporaban a la otan en
rusia lo que tenía que hacer era
aumentar su influencia a nivel
internacional aumentar la influencia
rusia rusa a nivel internacional cuál es
la influencia rusa a nivel internacional
de qué habla el kremlin cuando habla de
ser un país influyente porque
económicamente no es un país de la talla
de china o de la talla de eeuu
militarmente pues ya lo vemos como
ucrania lo está desgastando
estamos hablando de estos grupos
paramilitares como wagner la
desinformación los ciberataques es la
presencia rusa negativa
si pueden ser perfectamente porque
recordemos que el grupo wagner opera en
muchos países de áfrica sobre todo en
regiones que son muy ricas desde el
punto de vista energético en el caso de
libia por ejemplo ahí tiene digamos una
base operativa muy importante sobre lo
que significa este este grupo o este
ejército paralelo al ejército oficial en
eeuu perdón bm en rusia y eso
definitivamente pues le da una mayor
amplitud sobre lo que significa y la
forma en cómo lucía perfectamente puede
actuar en otros ámbitos no
necesariamente llevando inestabilidad
pero sí por lo menos ganando espacio de
influencia muy importantes en algunos
conflictos en los que occidente
participó y terminando siendo un fiasco
en los cuales pues en este caso rusia
podría estarse aprovechando así que yo
creo que rusia tiene digamos condiciones
más allá de lo que significa la guerra
nuclear yo más allá de abrir nuevos
frentes de guerra en europa que le
permiten digamos aprovecharse en otras
regiones en el mundo para hacer posible
eso recordemos también que en el caso de
américa latina había hablado también de
fortalecer lazos militares con venezuela
fortalecer lazos militares con nicaragua
fortalecer lazos militares con este cuba
que es digamos el aliado ha sido variado
como más histórico desde la crisis de
los misiles pero bueno tiene digamos
algunos alcances muy importantes también
con algunos países de américa del sur en
materia energética martín en materia
comercial no de la talla no del peso
como china digamos lo ha venido haciendo
pero si digamos creo que es paz es parte
digamos de todo este entramado
eur acionista de alexander dooling del
tratar de recuperar algunos espacios
importantes que tuvieron en su momento
cuando existían comunión soviética y
zaira cuál es su opinión cuál es esa
influencia rusa en el mundo que el
presidente putin ha dicho que va a ser
su carta a jugar si eso es y finlandia
se incorporan pues ellos tendrían que
expandir su presencia a nivel
internacional como lo hacen que es lo
que vende rusia qué es lo que hace a
rusia un actor influyente a nivel
internacional bueno a otros ya ha
perdido mucho la fuerza que tenía
digamos durante la época de la unión
soviética ya no tiene la misma
influencia que tuvo en el pasado pero
claro se perfila delante de muchos
países como una fuerza moral una fuerza
ética
y un poco se ve como algo que nos asocia
como grupo que tiene unas creencias en
relación a la familia y lo ven como
encontré una forma de estar en contra de
los eeuu y en contra digamos de la
expansión militar de los daños en otras
partes del mundo yo diría más bien que
en el espacio latinoamericano a veces
uno ve que volvemos de nuevo a los
discursos de la guerra fría donde se
quieren asociar con putin simplemente
porque no están de acuerdo con muchas de
las decisiones que la otan tal vez tomó
o las decisiones que eeuu ha tomado en
el pasado pero rusia ya no tiene ese
poder que tuvo en el pasado no obstante
es un país inmenso muy rico en minerales
con petróleo con gas
tiene la capacidad de apoyar a otras
economías por ejemplo economías en
áfrica que necesita un apoyo para
desarrollar su infraestructura pero ahí
parece que esto también es muy peligroso
porque muchos de estos países tanto
también en latinoamérica no quieren
posicionarse a favor de rusia o tampoco
en contra de rusia no aquí me parece que
latinoamérica estamos siendo muy
cautelosos y también lo vemos en otros
países de asia y también de áfrica donde
han mantenido buena relación con rusia
están a favor de mantener relaciones
comerciales pero todavía no están al
punto de querer arriesgar las
asociaciones o los lazos comerciales que
tienen con eeuu y en europa por por
rusia algo que tal vez pasó durante la
época de unión soviética donde se veían
bien claro dos bloques la salida
independiente de la coyuntura en la que
estamos con el conflicto en ucrania esta
atención entre rusia europa y eeuu en
suecia y finlandia son países que pueden
tener ejércitos pequeños pero están muy
bien entrenados ya han hecho a lo largo
de los años prácticas entrenamientos en
conjunto con la otan
son ejércitos técnicamente muy avanzados
y además suecia hace parte de toda la
industria militar global ellos han
producido armamento producen aviones
casa han producido diferentes equipos
para la guerra qué significa para la
otan que se incorpore en estos dos
países para este bloque
a mí no una presencia tan significante
son países importantes van a traer no
solamente
soldados y un armamento militar sino
también inteligencia nos vamos a ver que
los próximos años muchas de las guerras
que se llevan a cabo son guerra
cibernética y ya lo estamos viendo con
cráneo a mí no me parece que desde el
punto de vista de lo tan la nueva
incorporación de suecia y finlandia vaya
a ser algo por lo cual
beneficia y grandemente a la otan no ya
en el pasado como comenté anteriormente
suecia ha apoyado ejercicios militares
con lo tanto y también ha sido parte de
la invasión a afganistán así que como
tal a mí me parece que la edición la
adición de estos dos países a la otan es
bien simbólica también manda una señal a
rusia y hasta cierto punto va a ayudar a
que estos países empiecen a desarrollar
en particular en particular en suecia a
desarrollar un armamento militar más
fuerte un ejército más preparado para
confrontar lo que puede ser en el futuro
tal vez algún tipo de agresión de
rusia aunque yo lo veo poco probable en
el caso de suecia pero en el caso de
finlandia si podría ser podrían haber
algunos incidentes en la frontera por lo
tanto yo no creo que para dotan es un
beneficio como tal no pero sí creo que
va a llevar a estos dos países su
incorporación cambia la dinámica de lo
que es europa no lo ya estaban
acostumbrados a ver los países nórdicos
como muy neutrales y estamos viendo
ahora un mayor consenso pero no creo que
su adicción sea de gran envergadura para
gotham antonio cuál es su opinión sobre
esta incorporación que significa para la
otan pero aquí pienso lo mismo que ha
expuesto la doctora zaira por cuanto yo
creo que ya la otan históricamente ha
sido una conjunción de países con
altísimos niveles de especialización
militar yo creo que si hay algo que la
otan ha hecho desde que existe como tal
era tratar incluso de la de la época de
guerra fría tratar de ir muy adelante
desde el punto de vista militar a lo que
significó digamos su contraparte el
pacto de varsovia en aquel momento y yo
creo que con el fin de la guerra fría
quien se quedó muy atrás en el tema
militar pues fue prácticamente
rusia cuando quedó digamos perdida con
la disolución de la unión soviética que
fue digamos durante mucho tiempo y es
una permitió a la otan poder continuar
al ritmo que había venido teniendo
durante muchísimas décadas porque la
otan no sufrió ningún descalabro eso si
digamos con el canto en el caso del
pacto de varsovia y eso le permitió al
auto mantener ese paso constante de la
innovación y de la tecnología en materia
militar que ha permitido pues mantenerse
como tal hasta lara hasta la fecha así
que yo no creo tampoco que la el que se
agregue y suecia y finlandia pues vayan
a vaya a significar
una de un gran paso adelante sino que
simplemente pues se agregan dos miembros
más que vienen digamos de alguna manera
fortalecer el esquema de seguridad en
europa con en esta región que ya la
hemos hablado varias veces 2.300
kilómetros de frontera pues vienen ya de
alguna manera a jugar un papel
importante la otan cuando antes digamos
no lo tenía así que yo creo que no va a
haber mayor variación en ese sentido y
la otan va a mantenerse tal cual en esta
situación yo creo que la que la que
debería estar más preocupada acá sería
rusia por cuanto los únicos dos países
que no tienen contacto directo con su
frontera es bielorrusia y ucrania y de
ahí en adelante pues ya los tres países
bálticos tienen fronteras de contacto y
son miembros de la otan y ahora se
agregaría finlandia eventualmente
antonio pero esto no muestra de pronto
una otan un poco más robusta usted mismo
mencionaba que tal vez lo que evidencia
que rusia no pueda tener ningún tipo de
incursión en finlandia es que no tiene
la capacidad militar para
estar en dos frentes digámoslo así en
ucrania bombas finlandia
hablando hipotéticamente de un caso de
una de un ataque a finlandia y la otan
si se está mostrando un poco más robusta
sobre todo a nivel internacional después
de el retiro de las tropas de afganistán
que mostró una especie de ruptura o
discrepancia entre washington y los
aliados europeos no se está aquí
mostrando una otan un poco más fuerte
más musculosa y una rusia un poco
arrinconado y acorralada digámoslo así
sí yo creo que lo puteen en su momento
pensó que la guerra en ucrania o las
decisiones que se debían tomar respecto
a la gente respecto a la democracia
podrían descargar a la otan por
resquebrajar incluso a la misma unión
europea que desde el 2014 hasta la fecha
ha venido enfrentando crisis en alguna
serie de crisis sistémicas recurrentes
en materia económica de identidad de
como estructura yo creo que más bien la
que tengo crean ya terminó fortaleciendo
la unión europea y terminó fortaleciendo
la otan al punto de que repito
prácticamente suecia y finlandia se
estarían incorporando cuando más bien
era lo que se trataba de evitar así que
incluso si nosotros nos vamos un poquito
atrás vemos cuando en algún momento la
otan quiso incorporar a ucrania y quiso
incorporar a georgia vimos la respuesta
de putin en materia militar
principalmente en georgia la guerra de
2008 y vimos ahora lo que está pasando
buscar y entonces yo creo que finalmente
la otan se viene fortaleciendo aún más
harding e incluso la misma unión europea
pero estos fortalecimientos ocurren como
se dice en política internacional cuando
hay algún enemigo externo termina
fortalecía en dulce y nos olvidamos un
tiempo por las crisis si entrenas pero
eso es algo que digamos no está resuelto
así que yo creo que mientras prevalezcan
la crisis en ucrania yo creo que la
unión europea va a mantenerse sólida e
incluso la otan una vez que ésta se
termine será cuando lo que vaya a durar
yo creo que la unión europea tiene que
retomar de nuevo todo esto toda esta
situación de crisis interna que ha
venido enfrentando con cada uno de esos
miembros claro estamos hablando de un
actor importante a lo largo de estos
últimos días y es el presidente turco
recep tayib erdogán es zaira es difícil
entender a qué está jugando turquía
porque se muestra como un país mediador
ofrece
ankara y estambul como un escenario de
negociación entre rusia y ucrania pero
también le ha vendido aviones no
tripulados a los ucranianos después de
la anexión de crimea en el 2014 y ha
venido preparando un poco en materia de
abastecerle a ucrania algunos equipos
militares pero también está feliz
recibiendo a los ciudadanos rusos que
han salido del país recibiendo sus
ahorros en los bancos turcos y también
recibiendo los yates y las fortunas de
los de los millonarios rusos que están
trayendo su capital de los países de
europa occidental hacia hacia sus
fronteras a qué está jugando el
presidente turco qué papel está jugando
turquía allí
a mí me parece que toda esta estrategia
de fenomenal erdogán se ha aprovechado
en un momento eso político muy delicado
para sacarle provecho para ver de qué
forma esto lo beneficia y lo estaba
usando los sábados está jugando muy bien
el juego está tan temprano cuando hubo
las sanciones aquí en londres donde
muchos de los oligarcas tuvieron que
vivir con sus yates con sus
aviones a otros lados verdad muchos de
ellos terminaron en estambul y
terminaron en turquía y han sido
bienvenidos ahí pero por otro lado
también hay que ver cosas más prácticas
turquía tiene buenas relaciones
comerciales con ucrania volvemos a lo
que anteriormente les comentaba sobre
finlandia y rusia no hay mucha inversión
de parte de empresarios turcos en
ucrania y la misma forma también turquía
es un lugar un destino turístico para
muchos muchos rusos y ahí también mucha
inversión de parte de los rusos que
viven en el país no obstante él tiene
dos preocupaciones y una es el partido
de los trabajadores kurdos y otra es el
movimiento gülen que en el 2016 según él
porque esto un golpe de estado para que
para sacarlos del poder y eso son dos
preocupaciones que él tiene y como hemos
visto en el pasado suecia y finlandia no
han querido y
no ha querido deportar a algunos
activistas ya sea del partido de los
trabajadores kurdos o del movimiento
gülen y por lo tanto esto es algo que
erdogán tiene que subrayar porque es
turquía lleva una guerra ya de décadas
contra el partido de los trabajadores
kurdos y luego en siria hay una fracción
del partido de los trabajadores kurdos
en la cual también está buscando apoyo
del ámbito internacional en contra del
estado de de esta sección del partido de
trabajo del curso así que esos son sus
preocupaciones pero por otro lado hay o
hay una serie de ganancias que él quiere
aprovechar en este contexto una de ellas
tiene que ver con los lazos comerciales
que los une con ucrania pero también no
tiene interés en
en enfrentarse a putin no tiene que
hacerlo no además no olvidemos que
turquía está en control de este estrecho
en estambul que es muy importante tanto
comercial y militarmente así que tiene
una posición muy delicada que tiene que
manejar ahí así que creo que está
aprovechando todo lo que está sucediendo
pero a la misma vez también creo que
está claro de que él tiene una
preocupación y quiere que se le atienda
yo sé que ha dicho durante el día de hoy
que está en contra de que finlandia y
suecia entra en el mismo europea- yo
creo que solo va a ser difícil pero creo
que hay un espacio para negociación y
eso es lo que se está buscando si esa
ayuda hace referencia al estrecho de los
dardanelos y el bósforo que une
precisamente el mar mediterráneo con el
negro y permite el acceso a costas del
sur de rusia y a las costas del sur de
ucrania
antonio sobre este mismo tema que tanto
peso puede tener entonces turquía dentro
de la otan dentro del escenario
internacional para impedir este ingreso
de suecia y finlandia a nivel de la otan
de este organismo por los argumentos que
ya decía esa ira por por todas estas
críticas de refugio de algunos rebeldes
de algunos políticos del pp
etcétera
sí bueno recordemos que recientemente
dentro de todos estos argumentos a los
que ver dogan hizo referencia de por qué
se opone a la incorporación de finlandia
y de suecia recordemos que también
para que un miembro sea aceptado dentro
de la otan tiene que haber un acuerdo
unánime es decir no es una cuestión de
votación simplemente tiene que haber un
acuerdo unánime de todos los miembros y
con que uno se oponga pues prácticamente
digamos que en caso de que turquía se
opusiera haciendo valer esos argumentos
pues prácticamente
finlandia no estaría hinchando o incluso
suecia a pesar de que los parlamentos de
estos dos países ya han discutido
ampliamente la incorporación y ya están
pidiendo digamos las adhesiones que se
requieren pero es una cuestión de
acuerdo unánime y esto podría
eventualmente atraer hacia abajo la
posibilidad de que en finlandia y suecia
ingrese que es un por que es un poco
también la posición que tuvo en su
momento viktor orbán y hungría con el
tema de las sanciones que se oponía y
por tanto ahí hay todo un juego también
donde políticamente se le estaría
sacando provecho y erdogán como ya muy
bien lo dijo la doctora zaida pues juega
digamos con ese tipo de crisis ha jugado
con muchas crisis recordemos también que
las relaciones de turquía con rusia en
algunos momentos no han sido del todo
buenas sobre todo por la forma en cómo
se ha abordado la guerra en siria y
bueno ahí tenemos una presencia de rusia
militar en siria y fred y turquía
también juega un papel muy importante
con el tema de los kurdos en el norte
sobre todo en la ciudad de roya va
etcétera etcétera entonces ahí vemos
también que el tema de un acuerdo
unánime pues turquía podría ser una
carta importante que podría traerse
abajo eventualmente la incorporación de
estos dos países me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa quiero hacer las
conclusiones comienzo entonces con
antonio dejo a zaira para el cierre su
conclusión que va a suceder
bueno yo primeramente es pero yo creo
que lo que se desea es que esta guerra
en ucrania termine creo que es una
guerra que más allá de la valoración
geopolítica que putin haga es una guerra
sin sentido es una guerra en donde
prácticamente todos todos están
perdiendo ahí en europa e incluso a
nivel mundial porque las sanciones
económicas de sinaloa contra rusia
tienen una dimensión en realidad global
al extranjero creo que aquí todos
estamos perdiendo en esta situación de
la guerra democracia salida 30 segundos
para la conclusión adelante
desgraciadamente esta es una guerra que
va para largo y yo creo que todos estos
cambios que estamos viendo la nueva
adicción a la otan de nuevos países la
posición de turquía todo esto está
haciendo la guerra hasta cierto punto ha
afectado todo lo que está sucediendo en
europa no creo que vaya a finalizar
pronto y creo que lo que nos verán los
próximos meses especialmente en verano
va a ser va a ser crítico pues a zaira y
antonio les agradezco mucho por este
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
en toda américa latina ya vamos a ver
cómo se van desarrollando los hechos en
torno a este conflicto
después de esta invasión de rusia muchas
gracias a ustedes por la sintonía pueden
seguir dejando los comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
y pueden seguir viendo france24 sigan
con nosotros
[Música]